مرحبا بكم في نيوزلندا من قناه الجزيره في
اول رساله مصوره منذ اعلان نشرت كتائب
القسام الذراع المسلح لحركه حماس مقطع
فيديو يظهر الاسير الاسرائيلي لديها
ابراها من غيستو وبينما طالبت عائله
الاسير باطلاق سراحه بشكل فوري قال رئيس
الوزراء لاسرائيلي من يمينه نياهو ان نشر
الفيديو خدعه ستؤثر فرصه توصلي للصفقه
لتبادل الاسرار بدوره قال رئيس هيئه
الاركان الاسرائيلي المنصرف ان ملف
التبادل شهد تقدما قبل لا يتوقف بسبب
الانتخابات الاخيره
اعلنت السلطه الروسيه في القرم اسقاط
ثمانيه مسيرات اوكرانيه وصدى هجوم على
الجزيره بارتفاع عدد ضحايا قصف الى 40
قتيلا وبينما نفى للكرمني من المسؤوليته
عن الحادث
وحمل المضادات الاوكرانيه المسؤوليه قالت
كيف انما حدث
عن الاستهداف الرئيسي متعمد بدوره مصطفى
الاتحاد الاوروبي الهجوم بجريمه الحرب
اعدلت القوات الروسيه سيطرتها على مواقع
جديده جنوب مدينه بخموت لكن الجيش
الاوكراني نفذ ذلك وهددت نصف باحراق
الدبابات الغربيه التي ترسل الى اوكرانيا
عسكريه مع بلاروسيا في المقابل اعلنت
مباشره بدا برنامج جديد لتدريب قوات
الاوكرانيه في المانيا جهه اكد رئيس
الاوكراني حاجه بلاده الملح حال الدبابات
والمدفعيه للسعاده لوحده اراضيها
اصلا المدير العام للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه
الذريه رافائيل جروستي الى اوكرانيا وتوجه
الى محطه بيفدينو اوكرانيا للطاقه النوويه
الجنوبيه البلاد فقال غروس سي ان الوكاله
الدوليه لطاقه الذريه ستكون حاضره بشكل
دائم في اوكرانيا للمساعده في ضمان
السلامه والامن النوويين في ظل الصراع
والحرب المستمر
ان الرئيس الروسيه
التركيه راجع طيب اردوغان ملف انشائي مركز
زين لتوزيع الغاز في تركيا قال مساعد وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه للجزيره فقدت
المسبقيتها كان مورد موثوق للطاقه بعد
استخدامها كادت حرب
هذا وقد وضعت برلين خطه السباقيه لضمان
امداد الغاز من خلال المحطات العائمه
للغاز الطبيعي وفقا زمنيا قصير لمواجهته
تهديدات بقطع الغاز عن المانيا وتقول
برلين ان هذه المحطات العائمه قادره على
تامين 30 مليار متر مكعب من الغاز السنويا
اي ثلثا احتياجات المانيا من الغاز
[موسيقى]